racist blackface at an NFL game that's
what the sports news site dead spin is
alleging now check out their headline
which accuses a random Kansas City
Chiefs fan of wearing black face the fan
in question is a young boy he isn't in
black face at all he painted one side of
his face black and one side red don't
believe me well check out this other
photo now this is the second time in
recent weeks that a kid got accused of
racism merely for dressing up for a
football game a California middle
schooler was recently suspended for
wearing eye black to a game
I'm begging the media please stop trying
to accuse everyone of racism blackface
is bad but this ain't it chief